This video is sponsored by Skillshare, click the link in the description for more information.
Being someone who pleases people sounds, on
the face of it, like a very good idea. But
it is a pattern of behaviour riddled with
problems, as much for the perpetrator as for
their audience; the people-pleaser is someone
(who might at times be oneself) who feels
they have no option but to mould themselves
to the expectations of others, and yet, harbours
all manner of secret and at points dangerous
reservations and resentments. They act like
the perfect lover when their real feelings
are far darker; they give their assent to
plans they hate; and they confuse everyone
around them by failing to express, in due
time, with the requisite courage, their authentic
needs and ambitions. Putting it bluntly we
could say that the people pleaser is a liar.
It sounds brutal, but the people-pleaser is
lying for poignant reasons: not in order to
gain advantage, but because they are terrified
of the displeasure of others. To understand
– and potentially sympathise with – the
people-pleaser we need to look at their past
which almost invariably involves an early
experience of being around people – usually
a mother or a father – who seemed to be
radically and terrifyingly incapable of accepting
and forgiving certain necessary but perhaps
tricky facts about their child. Perhaps our
father flew into volcanic rage at any sign
of disagreement. To present an opposing political
idea, to suggest we wanted something different
to eat, to be frank about our tiredness or
anxiety, could threaten us with annihilation.
To survive, we needed to be acutely responsive
to what others expected us to do and say.
The very question of what we might really
want became secondary to an infinitely more
important priority: manically second-guessing
the desires of those on whom, at that time,
our lives depended. We didn’t always lie
out of fear; it was also often out of love
for someone we were profoundly attached to
but who was vulnerable in some way. We lied
out of a longing not to set off another marital
row, a desire to keep a depressive parent
in a good mood and to avoid adding a further
burden to what seemed like an already very
difficult or sad life. Who were we to make
things even more complicated for a fragile
person we cared for? However understandable
the origins of our behaviour, in the more
reflexive moments of adulthood, we might find
three paths out from these difficult patterns
of people-pleasing. The first relies on reminding
ourselves that our colleagues, partners and
friends are almost certainly very different
from the people around whom our anxieties
evolved in childhood. Most humans can cope
quite well with a bit of contradiction, a
dose of unwelcome information or an occasional
rejection, delivered with requisite politeness.
The other is not going to explode or dissolve.
We learned a very particular habit of relating
to the world around a group of people who
were not representative of humanity as a whole.
Secondly, we need to acknowledge the inadvertently
harmful side-effects of our behaviour. We
may genuinely have good intentions, but we
are endangering everyone by not speaking more
frankly. At work, we aren’t doing anyone
a service by withholding our doubts and reservations.
And in love, there is no kindness in staying
in a relationship simply because it seems
the other might not survive without us. They
will, but we will have wasted a lot of their
time through our sentimentality. Finally,
we can acquire the confidence to be artful
about the difficult messages we have to impart.
As a child we couldn’t nuance the messages
we wanted to send out. We didn’t know how
to craft our raw pain and needs into convincing
explanations. Now, it is open to us to be
firm in our own views – but extremely genial
as well. We can say ‘no’ while indicating
that we feel a lot of goodwill; we can say
someone is wrong without implying that they
are an idiot. We can leave someone, while
ensuring they realise how much a relationship
meant to us. We can – in other words – be
pleasant without being people-pleasers.
We partnered with Skillshare today as it is a fantastic starting point
for anyone also looking to learn new skills and they have given us an amazing offer to pass on to you.
The first 500 people to sign up using the link in the description
will receive a two month free trial.
If you haven't heard of Skillshare before it's home to thousands of classes
in Graphic Design, animation, web development, music, photography, design and more.
You can start learning how to do just about anything.
In two months you could easily learn the skills you need to start a new hobby or business.
Is there a project that you have been dreaming of completing but just aren't sure if you have the skills to do it?
Why not start now and sign up to Skillshare using the link below.